[Música]
las razas no existen biológicamente está
comprobado que hay más diferencia
genética entre los chimpancés y los
bonobos que entre una persona del norte
de europa
rubio aborigen del norte europeo y un
aborigen de australia o de méxico o de
sudamérica o de eeuu o de cualquier otra
parte del mundo
pero aún así la racialización si existe
que es la racialización es dotar a una
persona a partir de sus rasgos físicos
como el color de la piel de ciertas
características que no necesariamente
cumplen o encajan en esa persona que
sucedió de dónde viene el racismo porque
las razas no existen pero el racismo sí
que existe el racismo nace cuando una
región del mundo muy atrasada muy
salvaje muy violenta y muy brutal
llamada europa por cuestiones de que se
les cierra la ruta de la seda y el
transporte y la compra de especias se
lanza al océano y se encuentra con un
continente
pero resulta que el cristianismo prohíbe
la esclavitud porque todos somos hijos
de dios todos venimos del mismo creador
entonces ellos que necesitaban quien
explotar esas tierras quien las
trabajará hasta la extenuación para
poder ser procesos extractivistas de las
riquezas y de toda la cultura en estas
regiones se les ocurre decir que al
haber razas distintas tienen el derecho
divino y el permiso de esclavizar a la
gente porque no somos iguales en que se
basaron en las evidencias en las
diferencias evidentes del color de la
piel el fenotipo la lengua la religión
prácticas culturales y diferencias
fenotípicas
posteriormente cuando la biología
demostró que no había diferencias
radicales entre nosotros entonces
dijeron es que son salvajes
nosotros somos culturalmente superiores
y basándose en esta supuesta
superioridad de europa y de todas sus
prácticas y sus usos y costumbres
dijeron que todo aquel que no tenía sus
prácticas era inferior era un salvaje y
esos salvajes debían ser sometidos y
esos salvajes tenían que ser civilizados
lo que ellos entendían por civilización
evidentemente porque lo que ellos
entienden por civilización es los usos y
costumbres de sus pueblos aborígenes de
sus pueblos originarios de europa
a partir de ahí con estos permisos que
se van dando con estos maromas mentales
para ir justificando prácticas que no
debieran estar justificadas
estos grupos empiezan a explotar no
solamente en américa sino también áfrica
asia posteriormente hacen una conquista
del mundo para tener los recursos que
ellos muy amablemente se gastaron en
guerras
y en estas guerras ellos iban
dilapidando todas las riquezas que
mediante el trabajo esclavo la guerra la
explotación el saqueo y la violencia
obtuvieron de otras regiones del mundo
este es el contexto de lo siguiente hay
una cosa que sigue esta misma lógica que
nace en esta época que se llaman las
representaciones es como vamos a
representar a la gente que no entra al
fenotipo
europeo porque en esta lógica racista de
justificaciones para tener derecho a la
extracción nos dicen que hay un tipo que
es el tipo superior en términos físicos
que tiene que ser necesariamente blanco
ojo no es nada contra la gente de piel
blanca es contra un sistema llamado
racismo donde se van a privilegiar
ciertas personas y se va a condenar o se
le va a dificultar la vida a otras por
únicamente el color de la piel esto
quiere decir que todos los blancos son
beneficiados del sistema no porque si
eres pobre eres pobre y no importa que
tan blanco seas pobre te quedarás quiere
decir que por ser moreno y soy rico voy
a perderlo todo
porque si eres rico aunque seas moreno
rico te quedarás porque algo mágico de
este sistema es que no importa que tan
mal lo hagas si te una ser rico morirás
rico y si tú eres pobre no importa que
también lo hagas morirás pobre
y las estadísticas lo respaldan no
solamente es una apreciación personal
hay datos de oxfam y hay datos del inegi
que lo respaldan
pero bueno siguiendo con esto esta
plática que les estaba dando las
representaciones lo que hacen es
reafirmar estos prejuicios raciales que
tuve que es en al que nacieron desde
hace 500 años para justificar lo
injustificable y estas representaciones
nos llevan a poner a la gente de piel
blanca a la blanquita para ser más
precisos o sea al sistema no
necesariamente a los individuos al
sistema
y ponen la blanquita como lo deseable
como lo civilizado como lo limpio como
lo aspiracional esa frase tan divertida
que se usa en
publicidad especialmente en mexico no
eres aspiracional o sea la gente no va a
aspirar a ser como tú porque tú no eres
blanco
entonces nos hacen pensar que lo bueno
lo limpio lo puro lo mejor tiene que ser
perteneciente a este grupo y sobre todo
más allá del grupo a las prácticas y los
usos de costumbre y usos y costumbres
que heredamos desde hace 500 años de la
colonia del saqueo de la destrucción y
la barbarie que de europa llegó a las
tierras americanas secuestrando a
millones de seres humanos de áfrica
destruyendo sus vidas y sus relaciones
personales y trayendo los a este
continente para trabajar la tierra hasta
que se morían y si tenían hijos pues sus
hijos también eran condenados a la
esclavitud hasta que se morían
estas representaciones que ahora estamos
haciendo en los medios de comunicación
donde la mayoría de la gente es blanca
responde a esta misma dinámica hay una
cosa que se llama hegemonía cultural la
hegemonía cultural quiere decir que las
posiciones de poder e influencia serán
ocupadas única y exclusivamente por los
miembros de la
quien se parezca a la élite o sea
miembro de la élite será el único que
tiene el micrófono abierto y eso hasta
hace muy pocos años era un terreno
exclusivo de los hombres hombres blancos
y adinerados la mayoría de ellos de
culturas o tradiciones culturales
europeas porque tampoco se mezclaron
tanto porque hay una cosa que se llama
mestizaje que este este invento nebuloso
que hicimos sobre todo después de la
revolución mexicana donde se trataba de
que todos fuéramos lo mismo y entonces
para hacer todos lo mismo tratamos de
hacer una cultura en la que todos
supiéramos y que hicimos con esa cultura
en la que todos cumpliéramos a la
minoría étnica de este país que era la
gente de piel blanca los obligamos a
hablar en agua
los obligamos a hablar maya no verdad
de cindy géniz amos nos de sinti
iniciamos el estado hizo una campaña
para que todos se nos olvidará quiénes
éramos nos enseñaron a hacerse a sentir
vergüenza de ser lo que somos y los
medios de comunicación una y otra y otra
y otra y otra vez nos recuerdan que hay
algo malo en nosotros que no somos
aspiracionales que no somos suficiente
que no somos merecedores ni siquiera de
justicia porque cada vez que vemos en la
televisión que agarran a criminales
siempre nos presentan a los blancos
perdón a los morenos y siempre estamos
los morenos ahí
esposados y colocados no quiere decir
que no sean criminales claro que sólo
carpe lo son
pero cuando agarran a un criminal de
cuello blanco si es que lo agarran
nunca nos lo presente y sobre todo
cuando vemos las telenovelas o cuando
vemos las películas de las que yo mismo
soy participe cuando vemos las series
cuando vemos la publicidad siempre que
nos hablan de violencia y marginación
siempre indudablemente vamos a hacer los
morenos los que estemos ahí siempre
cada vez que hay una película que se
trata de la clase media baja y la clase
baja siempre es violenta grotesca animal
salvaje bruta in civilizada
hay violencia y violaciones hay un mundo
tan sórdido que yo viniendo de la clase
media-baja en la periferia de la ciudad
de méxico ecatepec de lo que digo sí
pero no
no puedo negar que no había eso pero
tampoco puedo decir que eso era todo
pero estas representaciones que hacen de
estos universos que evidentemente
directores productores guionistas no
conocen estas representaciones
criminalizan no solamente la pobreza
criminalizan un fenotipo
y ahorita en un momento más adelante les
voy a explicar por qué es peligrosísimo
criminalizar por qué pero bueno cuando
hablamos de la clase media alta y la
clase alta todos los personajes son
blancos
todo es comedia romántica todo es
hermoso todo es limpio todo desordenado
todos son universitarios y cuando tienen
estos errores algunos son egoístas
algunos son ligeramente violentos
algunos son medio mal horas basta que
haya algo una vuelta de tuerca en su
vida y entonces se encuentran la luz al
final del túnel y se vuelven más buenos
de lo que ya eran más blancos que el pam
pim así se vuelven
entonces yo me pregunto
y esta pregunta viene porque alguna vez
un director que yo recomendé a un amigo
para blanco de los altos de jalisco para
que hiciera un personaje el personaje
era un asesino y era un violador y al
final él se ganó todos los castings se
ganó toda la gente del público de la
producción y el último la última palabra
la tenía el dueño de la compañía o
cuando le preguntan al dueño de la
compañía
oye danos tu último voto tu aprobación
para que este compadre sea el personaje
principal el que se gane este actor este
gana este personaje dice no porque es
muy blanco para ser violador
porque es bien sabido que los blancos no
violan
me mata no importa lo que diga nuestro
premio nobel en su laberinto de la
soledad que dice que cortés violó a la
malinche que todos somos hijos de
mujeres violadas
pero resulta que en esta construcción
moderna no los blancos no violan la
violencia no puede ser ejercida desde
ahí porque la construcción que se hace
se hace desde un lugar de privilegio las
personas que nos cuentan la historia los
dueños de los medios de producción y
sobre todo los dueños de los mensajes
pertenecen a esta élite criolla a esta
élite blanca y desde su lugar de
privilegio nos quieren contar nuestras
propias historias y claro si ellos la
única relación que tienen con la vida
real era los jueves que iban con la nana
al mercado esas son sus baños de pueblo
pues desde ahí construyen las ficciones
y ellos dicen claro todos los prietos
son malos porque desde ahí en el mundo
son mala leche no nos suman la leche
solamente están equivocados porque eso
los medios de producción los medios de
creación de mensajes tienen que recaer
en las personas que vamos a representar
que si voy a hablar de cine y en el cine
va a haber indígenas tengo que darle a
la cámara a una directora indígena y en
su nueva en su otra manera de producir y
en su otra manera de contar historias se
cuenten a sí mismos para que el poder
hegemónico y las representaciones
hegemónicas que tanto daño le han hecho
este país empiecen a cambiar y estar en
otro lugar para que nos empezamos a
contar otra historia de nosotros mismos
no se olviden que la historia que nos
contamos las narrativas los mitos
fundacionales culturales son los que nos
dan identidad es el cuento que nos
contamos lo que nos dicen lo que somos
lo que aspiramos ser
y lo que podemos ser alguna vez una una
académica y un cubata me preguntaba
junto con otros compañeros cuando
ustedes eran niños todos morenos se
sintieron identificados alguna vez con
algún actor
y nos quedamos callados porque cuando
éramos niños no había actores morenos y
los que había solamente estaban para
abrir la puerta para saltar para violar
o para limpiar el piso tiene algo de
malo eso no la gente que abra la puerta
que limpia el piso no tiene nada de malo
pero porque no podemos aspirar a más si
según el inegi hay 9 millones de
millonarios en mexico que tienen la piel
morena porque somos el 80% de la
población porque luego entonces no hay
el 80% de actores
series películas y telenovelas en teatro
la compañía nacional de teatro es
predominantemente blanca en una nación
que es predominantemente morena
porque no hay morenos en las revistas
porque no hay morenos en la publicidad
claro claro que están prestan cuando
estamos hablando de un kilo de ayuda
claro que están cuando estamos hablando
de combate a la criminalidad claro que
están cuando estamos hablando de
programas para acercar a la gente de las
drogas como la última campaña contra las
drogas del gobierno federal
ahí sí todos son morenos claro porque
los blancos no se drogan
estas esto que les estoy diciendo y voy
a lo que les había mencionado hace rato
de por qué es peligroso
por que invisibiliza
porque cuando tú dices que esta persona
con estas características físicas con
esta condición de pobreza
que ni siquiera habla español como
primera lengua o no habla español en
absoluto es una persona que es un
criminal
y todos se ven iguales además y entonces
cuando matan a uno de esos décimos
mataron a uno más
e invisibilizar a un grupo criminalizar
a un grupo lo condena al exterminio
porque cuando hace algunos años un
narcotraficante le declaró la guerra al
narco y puso a otro narcotraficante a
hacerle la guerra al narco dijeron todos
son daños colaterales y entonces nos
venían números y números y números de
asesinatos
pero todos pobres
o indígenas
o morenos de la marginalidad no quiere
decir que todos aquí no suframos la
violencia todos la sufrimos todos la
padecemos pero lo cierto es que cuando
matan a una persona que se identifica
como inferior como salvaje como animal
como brutal no nos duele igual
por eso desaparecen a 43 estudiantes en
este estado
tantos años después sigue sin haber
justicia porque son los desechables
e invisibilizar y criminalizar mata
destruye
la cera
y rompe
familias sociedades estados
y lo que tú quieras nos rompe el racismo
las representaciones y como pongamos a
la gente en frente de la pantalla y no
nada más en frente de la pantalla sino
atrás de la pantalla porque yo que
trabajo en los medios de comunicación
les puedo decir que la mayoría de los
directores productores y guionistas y
demás son de piel blanca y casi todos
casi todos obviamente no todos ellos
pero casi todos son de la clase media
alta educada poseedora de la cultura que
además es cultura europea
porque todo lo que es viene del folklore
europeo es la gran cultura y lo que no
viene del folklore europeo es mero
folklore
son artesanías bueno
estas construcciones esta necesidad de
hacernos sentir vergüenza de lo que
somos
se tiene que acabar
tenemos que estar al frente y detrás de
la cámara contando otras historias donde
todos quepamos donde no se trata de que
los blancos se van a se sataniza los
bancos no se satanizó un sistema racista
no es contra la piel blanca es contra la
blanquito contra el sistema de valores
racistas clasistas que heredamos desde
hace 500 años que nos enseñaron a sentir
vergüenza de ser lo que somos y saben
que yo ya me cansé gracias
[Música]